Hey, Marvel fans.
I'm joined by Sarah Finn.
How are you doing?
- Hello.
I'm great.
It's very exciting
to be here tonight.
How are you?
I'm-- I'm speechless.
This is incredible.
What has it been like to
see these young adults
that you cast grow into the
characters that they are now?
Yeah, it's a little
emotional, isn't
it, to think about the journey.
And when we first cast Tom,
and Zendaya, and Jacob,
I think Jacob's screen test
was his first time he ever
set foot on a set in his life.
And now to see how
far they've come
and have the end of
the trilogy here,
I'm very excited
to see the movie.
I haven't seen it yet.
I'm very excited to see it
and to see how the fans react.
Well, you've done an
incredible job at casting.
Like, it's this-- kudos to you.
What was it like
bringing back characters
like Willem and Alfred?
Am I allowed to
talk about that?
I don't think so, Megan.
[LAUGHTER]
I mean, it was in the trailer.
Come on, Sarah.
I think you can.
Yeah, it's bonkers.
It's-- this movie is as big
as anything we've ever done.
And it's really exciting to
see how they're all going
to interact on screen together.
Did you ever think
that would happen?
No.
No, I didn't.
I didn't.
When I first heard the
idea for the movie,
I thought, this is impossible.
But--
But here we are.
Here we are.
Was there a moment where
you're like, I don't
know if we can pull this off?
This is so big.
This is the biggest
Spider-Man film yet.
Yes.
Luckily, on my end,
a lot of the cast
was already in existence
that I had cast
and from other wonderful
casting directors
who worked on this film
in much earlier versions.
So in terms of
pulling it off, I'm
going to toss that ball to the
incredible production people,
our producers Amy,
Rachel, Kevin Feige, Jon
Watts, everyone who
worked so hard to pull
off a movie on this scale.
[MUSIC PLAYING]